hey guys i'm ryan right and though this
would be crazy we're gonna review the
trailer today for a film called
underdogs don't know anything about it
it's getting a lot of attention and it's
an animated film so I thought who better
than crazy Sundays a great what's your
favorite whoever wins is the real
champion
if you insist the bullying is over but
we his rival ace returns after seven
years the real battle begins
thank you my child because its
destruction begins now let's play real
soccer we need a little help some
friends the first thing there is to your
life yeah an insane asylum now the
world's smallest hero is the mistress
affix to the treaty Regina my Ferraris
were can help in this game you must
defeat the world's greatest team
we're gonna use our heads
fun it looks cute first off that cash I
know what half of them really that's it
Ariana Grande let's hold on like was amo
Katie Holmes Matthew Morrison who's that
Oh Glee don't watch Glee the animation
kind of looks like Howdy with a Chance
of Meatballs yeah I mean the animation
to me doesn't look all that different
it's still good what I admire about
Pixar is their animation tends to change
a lot it does yeah as opposed to a lot
of other companies with animation kind
of stays similar a lot of the time so
this animation doesn't look the most
unique but this is a movie intended for
families definitely and for kids and
stuff so as far as the demographic
they're aiming to satisfy yeah I think
it'll satisfy that demographic it will
but I feel like in the beginning their
demographic was different from the end
of the trailer just because you know at
the beginning it's kind of like Oh cute
you know puppy love that's adorable kind
of deal and then seven years later all
of a sudden you're like whoa these guys
kind of look badass you know but I don't
want to mess with them
well like it could appeal to more than
just kids I like the theme of having
like the ultimate bully you know taking
that bully theme and taking it to a
whole new extreme of he comes back to
the town aisle owns it and it's gonna
redo everything I want to know how it
becomes his town how does that just
happen I don't know he's some rich
soccer player now right I know the
trailer was slightly confusing I feel
like I need to go over it again Blanco
in the beginning them as kids it's so
thank you but foosball characters come
to life yeah that's actually pretty cool
that's cool I haven't seen that done and
I think that's pretty neat and they
credited a few names in this trailer but
I feel like you could give great
voice-over talent for all those foosball
characters and you could have wonderful
like dynamic what I want is that for all
them to be distinguished I don't want it
to all be oh they all have the same
personality right I want them all to
have you need
personalities and I think that could be
really fun I feel like they could be the
highlight of this film yeah their own
spin-off me but I love also how the
foosball players themselves don't just
come to life in they're really awesome
right away they stay small that to me is
really intriguing still goes with the
theme of underdogs because they're small
so he has to learn how to get better at
soccer by playing sort of foosball with
these guys well this point is flat-out
soccer that's what it looked like they
were where they just little people
playing soccer or they in their own
foosball world when they're training and
stuff oh [ __ ] and then they call
underdogs are the underdogs the
characters of because it starts off with
a bunch of shoulder and there's the
bully and then is it this guy and his
friends who become part of the team I
think it's the guy who's friends and the
foosball players cuz I don't think he
had a lot of friends in yeah or it might
just be the foosball players point I
don't know you guys are bitter enough
for us please
you gotta make sure you guys know it's
not like what you just watch this
trailers cleared up for us it's pretty
simple it's a family oriented film it
looks like it's gonna have some good
messages meet like the hero will conquer
maybe the bully learns a lesson or two
as well it has its predictable formulas
but at the end of the day it's it's
meant for kids and I think you could do
worse than this I think it'll be cute I
think it'll be very enjoyable I think
it'll be very light-hearted but also
have a deeper message that like you know
kids are society's will pick up on
I feel like though that I don't think
you'll be a huge hit there's nothing
about it that seems that much different
to make it a huge hit to me it doesn't
seem like a hundred percent complete or
that it was thoroughly worth yeah this
trailer looks like a work in progress
though yeah it doesn't look like the
films almost done yeah it looks like
they're still doing touch-ups and stuff
I mean at the same time I feel like that
could be a huge factor because I know a
lot of people have issues with that
that's why a lot of people don't watch
anime I think that this film could have
some really cool animation shots like
especially if the soccer game they have
in the finale the trailer doesn't really
show you enough of what cool animation
shots there could be from what the
trailers showing us it looks like to me
a good straight-to-dvd valve but I feel
like that this has potential to really
surpass whatever this trailer is
conveying right now but I mean probably
captured if like I'm babysitting or
something anyway guys I might babysit a
child in an appropriate manner
let's stop kids might be watching this
video no I won't babysit you if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and Alyssa has a
channel too Alyssa be crazy you should
check out her channel awesome
and Danny praying hello friend good to
see your videos I am from Germany and a
big fan your posters are very great do
you have a Joker poster all the best for
you and your beautiful girls on your
couch I am not gay but I love you hahaha
you might say that you know you're not
gay but you love me dude you're German
all Germans are like bisexuals right
back me up on this one
it does turbans are very much
exploratory kind of guys if anyone's
open-minded it's the Germans I think we
learned that from history I have plenty
of German friends and they're all
bisexual yes it is a germinal no see and
you're not bisexual point proven Rashad
Jackson give a brother a shout-out check
out ask s on YouTube page he called you
out along with Gator Martin and Tyrone
Magnus ok so what now I'm curious
there's like this ultimate reaction
things people are trying to put together
I guess I kind of want to be a part of
it just do it they called you out so so
take the challenge ok but ok
they say gator Martin Tyrone Magnus
great gator Martin he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Tyrone Magnus complete [ __ ] met both
of them incredibly rude Martin was
awesome gator Martin you can go [ __ ]
nuts
they were really really cool I did meet
Gator Martin he's really cool I never
met Tyrone Magnus his channel is more
popular than this one I've seen his Star
Wars video that was pretty funny [ __ ] if
there was a hierarchy of trailer
reactors you know Tyrone Magnus might
have more subs but I think I'm better
looking than him
I can't comment on those two are Black
Gate or Martin Tyrone Magnus but I'm
pretty sure I got a bigger penis than
them too I kind of don't want to be
associated with people that much smaller
than me in life half asian half Italian
Italians are known to have long slums
locater Martin Tyrone Magnus see this
video hey it's two black reactors and
then one white half white I don't know
we really don't can make it or do
together Gator and Tyrone like give me
in the center
yeah its sandwich ourselves yeah we
should do this where are you going with
this
I don't know it started off with making
fun of them - how I have a bigger penis
- how we can all have a three-way so
eater and Tyrone Tyrone would be he's
buff and he could [ __ ] me hard have fun
with that all right that would hurt we
should do this reaction together